اعتبر احد اسوا الاعاصير التي ضربت جزر
البهاما خلال 60 عاما مضت فقوته تعادل قوه
اربعه اعاصير معا واثاره الاقتصاديه بقيت
حتى وقت ليس ببعيد الاعلى في تاريخ
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه انه اعصار
اندرو المدمر فما قصته في الرابعه عشر من
اغسطس عام
1992 بدات عاصفه استوائيه في التشكل في
شمال المحيط الاطلنطي قبل ان تنتقل عبر
جزر البهاما وتصل الى اليابسه على اطراف
ولايه فلوريدا بعد عشره ايام من تشكلها
استمر الاعصار الذي صنف بالدرجه الخامسه
في التحرك بسرعه 150 ميلا في الساعه اي ما
يعادل قوه اكثر من اربعه اعاصير معا ثم
عبر نحو خليج المكسيك وهبط في ولايه
لويزيانا فاجتاحت الفيضانات الساحل وهدمت
سلاح المنازل ضربت الرياح العاتيه المنازل
والمدارس وتضررت العديد من المباني
والعقارات السياحيه كما تدمرت الطرق
الرئيسيه فتعطلت المواصلات وتوقفت وسائل
النقل واغلقت المطارات والموانئ تحرك
الناس تحت الامطار الغزيره وفي كل مكان
بحثا عن فرص النجاه فيما قتل الاعصار 65
شخصا وتسبب في نزوح 250 الف شخص فيما ترك
مئات الالاف بلا ماوى اعتبرت مقاطعه ميامي
ديد الاكثر تضررا حيث دمر الاعصار فيها
اكثر من 125 الف منزل وشرد 160 الف شخص
كثير منهم لم يعودوا ابدا الى ديارهم بل
ان الجزء الجنوبي من المقاطعه فقد على اثر
الكارثه سبعه وعشرين في المئه من سكانه
بعد خمسه ايام من حدوث العاصفه وصل سته
الاف جندي والف من مشاه البحريه للمناطق
المتضرره حيث تم بناء مساكن مؤقته وخيام
للاسر المتضرره كما تم تامينهم بالمساعدات
ولوازم الحياه الاساسيه
على اثر الكارثه تعرض الرئيس الامريكي
جورج بوش لانتقادات واسعه على ما وصف برد
الفعل البطيء اضافه الى ما تحمله الاقتصاد
الامريكي من خسائر قدرت بنحو سبعه وعشرين
مليار دولار كما ادت الى افلاس الكثير من
الشركات خصوصا شركات التامين
[موسيقى]